il y à 22 ans la sphère g jane's
bouleversé le pays
c'était la première fois qu'une histoire
d'agression sexuelle par un entraîneur
était médiatisée d'un océan à l'autre
james a fait six victimes connues dont
l'ancien joueur de la ligue nationale de
hockey et sheldon kennedy
on avait crié plus jamais et pourtant
l'enquêté révèle qu'entre 1998 et 2000
18 340 entraîneur du monde du sport
amateur au pays ont été accusés de
méfait sexuelle 222 ont été reconnus
coupables on évalue le nombre de jeunes
victimes à plus de 600 et ce n'est pas
tout trente autres cas sont toujours
devant les tribunaux
on sait qu'un problème depuis longtemps
dans le contexte sportif qui est des
abus sexuels qui se passe mais de voir
ces schaeffler ses pertes et tente
l'ancien olympien sans jack kirby
aujourd'hui professeur à l'université de
winnipeg et experte internationale en
matière d'abus dans le sport estime
qu'il pourrait y avoir plusieurs autres
milliers de cas qui n'ont jamais été
rapporté
les accusations criminelles répertoriés
par l' enquête touche 36 sports
différents
les sports les plus pratiqués le hockey
arrive en tête avec 86 personnes
accusées le soccer on compte 40
aucun sport n'est à l'abri est ce que
certains sports pourrait se dire bof
c'est le hockey c'est la gymnastique ça
nous concerne pas jamais c'est en fait
la première clé cuir ouvre la porte pour
un prédateur
nous avons demandé à 35 organisations
sportives nationales si elle publie une
liste des entraîneurs et des bénévoles
suspendus ou radiés des 25 organisations
qui ont répondu seulement 3 le fond mais
sans préciser la raison de la sanction
il n'y a donc aucun moyen de savoir qui
est sanctionné pour des gestes à
caractère sexuel
la transparence est nécessaire c'est
devrait être au sein de la culture pour
n'importe quel club pour faire des vrais
changements à long terme protéger nos
enfants
la ministre fédérale des sports kirsty
duncan a présenté en juin une série de
mesures que doivent suivre les
organismes sportifs pour éliminer le
harcèlement et les abus les résultats
restent floues
[Musique]
des collègues à moi en ontario où
clairement démontré que les procédures
qui ont été mises en place n'ont pas
porté fruit
et aussi on eu très peu d'évaluation en
recherche sur les retombées de ce qui se
fait actuellement
on peut pas le vérifier mais on à damas
a levé russie selon les experts
le sport doit cesser d'être juge et
partie en matière d'abus sexuels et le
sport ça reste un des derniers domaines
dans lequel on est régulée par soi même
donc le sport réguler ses propres
politiques reçoit ses propres plainte
il faut qu'ils aient un leadership et ce
leadership l'eau ça peut pas être une
entité qui avait confiné intérêts
alloués
[Musique]